I remember my birthday party
Churchill's out move around everything
went black it's okay now you back back
from O'Hare
that's clearly there's a place reach
bring those things back oh you dog
are you happy mommy
[Music]
I should never have shown you that place
what you do
if you cheat death there's a price to be
paid I needed more time
sometimes dead is better
[Music]
have you done something it's not too
late to undo it
what is it each church honey we think
Church ran away sweetheart yeah yeah it
ran away
Wow he was outside my window last night
sweetheart I you know maybe he came back
last night
look he's right there
let's call you I wasn't ready to say
goodbye to her scaring me just tell me
what you're talking diddle I thought she
died I had to bring it back there's a
place rage deep in the woods beyond the
pet cemetery brings things back
are you happy mommy
I don't want her here either so these
are the trees up there yeah they're
warnings the local tribes carved him
before they fled fled and they knew the
power in that place they felt its Pole
they came to believe that those woods
belonged to something else the the
ground was bad so they moved on but
there is something up there
something that brings things back so
what happened you dog Jud he came back
just likes Danny B said he would but he
was changed it was when he went after my
mother that my daddy put him down for
the second time
sometimes dead is better
[Music]
[Music]
I know you're up here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so many trees it's beautiful right
that's definitely not Boston here we go
okay so what do you think wow this whole
place is ours
I've even gotten to throw in a whole
forest as a new backyard
[Music]
it was a myth kids used to dare each
other go into the woods at night they
knew the power of that place they feared
it those woods belong to something else
[Music]
the round is bad it may be just some
crazy folktale but there is something up
in those woods something it brings
things back
sometimes dead is better if you want to
make a truly terrifying movie you have
to go back to the master of horror
himself Stephen King Pet Sematary was
known as Stephen King's most terrifying
book they're places in this world then
bring things back to the king and pet
cemetery
he carries into a deeper level of what
real horror is excuse there are people
in your life you cannot do without what
would you do to bring them back I know
what you're thinking you're doing but
they don't come back the same this is
gonna take people on a wild trip
huggy dollar
sometimes dead is better in the woods
today
la discovered a charming little land
work but that secretary place to bury
our pets and remember them which seems
scary but it's not perfectly natural
just like dying is natural whole town's
been using this place for generations
folks make a kind of ritual out of it
it's not some campfire story saw these
are the trees up there they're warnings
the local tribes carved and before they
fled they fear that place there's
something up there something that dates
way back
those would belong to something else
something that cat was dead he'll bring
these things back
[Music]
I know what you're thinking you're doing
but they don't come back the same wit
scoyoc you daughter I should never have
shown you that place your child is not
the only thing that will come back area
is broke
we have a second chance
sometimes debt is better
[Music]